N
NEW YORK CITY AND THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
REPUBLICANS ARE OUTLINING THEIR
BOLD VISIONS FOR AMERICA NEAR
THE MIDTERMS AND GIVING THEM A
CLEAR CONTRAST ON THE MATTER OF
POLICY SOME DEMOCRATS.
THE G.O.P.'S COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA PUT IN THE SPOTLIGHT ON
THE ISSUES THAT ACTUALLY MATTER
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
INFLATION, CRIME, BORDER
SECURITY.
ALL FITTING INTO THESE FOUR
CATEGORIES.
AN ECONOMY THAT A STRONG, A
NATION THAT IS SAFE, A FUTURE
THAT IS FILLED WITH FREEDOM AND
A GOVERNMENT THAT THAT IS
ACCOUNTABLE.
HERE'S REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
TODAY.
>> THEY CONTROL THE HOUSE, THE
SENATE, THE WHITE HOUSE, THEY
CONTROL THE COMMITTEES,
AGENCIES, IT IS THEIR PLAN.
THEY HAVE NO PLAN TO FIX ALL OF
THE PROBLEMS THEY CREATE.
>> THERE CAN BE HOPE,
OPPORTUNITY SO THAT WHEN YOU
WAKE UP IS NOT JUST GOING TO
WORK FOR YOURSELF IS TO GO TO
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR KIDS
CAN HAVE A BETTER FUTURE.
THERE'S NOWHERE ELSE IN THE
WORLD WITH THAT OPPORTUNITY
EXISTS.
>> MOMS AND DADS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY THEY KNOW THAT PARENTS
ARE THE PRIMARY STAKEHOLDERS AND
THEIR KIDS EDUCATION WHICH IS
WHY WE WILL PASS A PARENT'S BILL
OF RIGHTS.
SPEED TO COMPARE WITH
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
WITH THE BIGGEST TEACHERS UNION
IN THE COUNTRY.
YEP WHO PUSH SCHOOL SHUTDOWNS
AND MASKS FOR YOUR KIDS
ADDRESSING THE LEFT-WING
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
>> President Biden: KEVIN
McCARTHY UNVEILED WHAT HE
CALLS A COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
THAT IS A THIN SERIES OF POLICY
GOALS.
WITH LITTLE OR NO DETAIL.
THAT SOUND LIKE HYPERBOLE BUT IT
GENERALLY IS.
REMEMBER I GOT BEAT UP IN THE
CAMPAIGN THAT SAYING THAT I
WANTED TO UNIFY THE COUNTRY AND
UNIFY THE PARTIES.
USED TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED A WHOLE
BUNCH.
THE MAGA REPUBLICAN CONTROLLED
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY RIGHT NOW.
THIS NOVEMBER YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE
TO BE A NATION OF HOPE, UNITY,
AND OPTIMISM.
OR A NATION OF FEAR, DIVISION,
AND DARKNESS.
>> Jesse: VERY INSPIRING BY
THE PRESIDENT SO JUDGE JEANINE
WOULD YOU MAKE OF KEVIN
McCARTHY AND THE WHOLE
REPUBLICAN PARTIES COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA?
>> Judge Jeanine: I THINK THE
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA IS ONE
THAT REFLECTS THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE ARE INTERESTED IN.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
INFLATION, HOW MUCH IT'S CANNOT
CAUSE FOR YOUR FOOD IN YOUR
TRUCK TO FILL UP.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN EDUCATION
JUST LIKE PARENTS ARE THE
ORIGINAL STAKEHOLDERS WANT TO
COME TO THEIR KIDS.
THE PARENTS BILL OF RIGHTS
FINALLY, THEY ARE INTERESTED IN
PORT SECURITY THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY AND WRAPPING IT UP
AGAIN SO THAT WE ARE NOT YOU
KNOW, IN A POSITION WHERE WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO AT LEAST AFFORD GAS.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE ABOUT
ALL THIS, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN IN POWER FOR TWO YEARS.
EVERYTHING HAS GONE TO IN A HAND
BASKET FOR TWO YEARS.
THE PRICE OF EVERYTHING IS GONE
UP, THE PRICE TO FOR YOUR CAR
HAS GONE UP, CRIME IS GONE UP,
INFLATION IS GONE UP.
2 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE ENTER THE
COUNTRY IN THE LAST YEAR.
YOU KNOW WHO THEY ARE WHO IS A
WHO IS A CRIMINAL.
THEY COULD BE PRIESTS I DON'T
KNOW.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT WE DON'T
KNOW WHO THEY ARE, WE DON'T HAVE
A PLACE TO BURY THEM.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE WE ARE
BURYING THEM, BUT HERE'S THE
BOTTOM LINE.
WHEN JOE BIDEN WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT HOPE, OPTIONS, AND YET THE
REPUBLICANS.
THIS GUY DOESN'T OFFER ANYTHING
OTHER THAN HATE, AT MAGA
REPUBLICANS.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
GOING HUNGRY WHEN JOE BIDEN CAME
IN OFFICE, HE'S TALKED ABOUT
BUSINESSES BEING CLOSED THAT'S
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE THE
ONES WHO LOCK EVERYTHING DOWN
AND THEY DIDN'T EVEN WANT THE
VACCINE OUT UNTIL AFTER
DONALD TRUMP WAS GONE.
JOE BIDEN HAS GONE THROUGH ALL
THE MESS BY UNNECESSARY SPENDING
AND HE IS CREATED INFLATION THAT
IS LITERALLY PUT US INTO A
RECESSION.
>> Jesse: THE PRODUCERS OF
HONEY WE JUST GOT SOME FRESH NEW
SOUND FROM HILLARY CLINTON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS BUT I
BEEN TOLD IT'S PRETTY
PROVOCATIVE LET'S LISTEN.
>> I REMEMBER AS A YOUNG
STUDENT, TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO PEOPLE GET BASICALLY
DRAWN IN BY HITLER?
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
I'D WATCH NEWSREELS I SEE THIS
GUY STANDING UP THERE RANTING
AND GRIEVING, PEOPLE SHOUTING
AND RAISING HER ARMS WHAT IS
HAPPENED OF THESE PEOPLE?
WHAT ARE THEY BELIEVE THAT?
WE SAW THE RALLY IN OHIO THE
OTHER NIGHT, DONALD TRUMP IS
RANTING AND RAVING FOR MORE THAN
AN HOUR AND YOU HAVE THESE ROADS
OF YOUNG MEN WITH HER ARMS
RAISED.
>> Jesse: DID I SEE A HITLER
SALUTE AT A TRUMP RALLY?
>> ALSO THE CONFLATION OF THE
TRUMP RALLY AND PEOPLE WHO FEEL
POLITICALLY DISCONNECTED TO THE
RISE OF HITLER?
THAT MAY BE A BIT OF A STRETCH
AND ACCORDING TO GODWIN'S LAW
SHOWS ALREADY LOST THE ARGUMENT
BECAUSE WHENEVER YOU HAVE TO
INVOKE HITLER OR NAZISM TO MAKE
YOUR POINT YOU WILL FAILED.
SHE HAS FAILED FOR PRESIDENT
TWICE.
NO ONE REALLY WANTS TO HEAR WHAT
SHE HAS TO SAY, SHE
ABOUT ANY NEW IDEAS, SHOULD NOT
FIGHT ABOUT EASE PEOPLE'S PAIN
AND JOE BIDEN STANDING UP THERE
WITH THE MOST POWERFUL TEACHERS
UNION IN THE COUNTRY PARENTS
HAVE NOT FORGOTTEN ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC.
PARENTS ARE WATCHING THIS OR A
POLITICAL WILL FOR ENTIRE WORLD
WAS SHUT DOWN.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT HIM ALL THE
MONEY AT THESE TEACHERS UNIONS
GIVE THE DEMOCRATS, PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN POWER AND ALL THE DO IS
ENRICH EACH OTHER.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT GOING HOW
DARE YOU.
ERIN TO COME UP WITH THE PARENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS.
THEY WANT REPUBLICANS, BUT THEY
CERTAINLY ARE LISTENING NOW.
BECAUSE THEY CAN AFFORD ANYTHING
AND THEY HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
OSTRACIZED FROM THEIR KIDS
SCHOOLS.
HILLARY CLINTON COMPARING
ANYTHING TO HITLER?
>> Jesse: I FEEL IT WE
WOULD'VE SEEN THIS BEFORE
DONALD TRUMP HAD THIS ON A RALLY
OVER THE WEEKEND IT'S FRIDAY AND
VISIT THE FIRST TIME I'M HEARING
ABOUT THE WHOLE CROWD THROWING
UP SALUTES?
THIS IS NOT A REAL STORY.
>> Tyrus: SON-IN-LAW JARED
KUSHNER I BELIEVE I HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THAT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED.
THERE'S BEEN TIMES MY LIFE WERE
YOU TRYING TO DEBATE IN
SOMEONE'S LOSING A DEBATE IN
THE GO-TO THE COLLIE OF YOUR
SKIN OR SUMMING ABOUT THE HOW MY
PATH BACKWARDS IS A DESPERATE
ATTEMPT OF SOMEONE WHO HAS LOST
AIRMEN.
THEY'VE LOST THE ARGUMENT AND
THE ONLY TALK AND ECHO CHAMBERS.
SHE IS SO LAZY WITH THAT SHE
WOULDN'T EVEN STAND UP AND SHOW
ANY EMOTION.
SHE JUST SAT THERE IN HER CHAIR
I THOUGHT YOU JUST SO CONFUSED
AND HOW PEOPLE WORK TALKING LIKE
HITLER.
THEY DON'T EVEN PUT A MOTION AND
THOUGHT THEY JUST SPEAK TO HEAR
THEMSELVES SPEAK THE GOOD NEWS
IS PEOPLE ARE
STARTING TO RESPOND.
WE START TO SEE PEOPLE
CHALLENGING THE WOKEN OF DOING
IT NOW.
THE ONLY THING THAT I'M
CONCERNED WITH HIS OR
REPUBLICANS HAVE A REAL
OPPORTUNITY HERE BUT JUST LIKE
ANYTHING IF THEY WANT TO BUILD
ANYTHING, BILL BECK AMERICA
ET CETERA HOWEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL IT.
THE BLUEPRINT NEEDS TO BE SOLID.
WE NEEDED HER PLANS, THE
REPUBLICANS IF THEY GET IN I
DON'T DO ANYTHING THAN THEY ARE
NO BETTER THAN WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW.
SO MANY PLANTS AND MANY PEOPLE
TO GET IN, FORGET THE LIP
SERVICE TO ME ABOUT HOW HER TO
DO IT AND GET THIS COUNTRY BACK
ON TRACK.
>> Jesse: I THINK I KNOW WHAT
SHE WAS DOING SHE MET UP INTO
STUPID TO REALIZE GNOME IS DOING
AT THE DONALD TRUMP RALLY OR SHE
KNOWS THAT IT'S B.S., BUT SHE
JUST WANTS TO SAY TRUMP, HITLER,
SALUTE BECAUSE OF THE MEDIA IS
TO WRITE STORIES AND SAY TRUMP,
HITLER, SALUTE.
THAT'S THE MOVE?
I KNOW THE MOVE.
I KNOW HOW SHE WORKS.
>> AND FAIRNESS I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU TAUGHT ABOUT FULLY.
THERE WAS THIS PICTURE THAT THEY
SAID WAS THAT A TRUMP RALLY I
KNOW IF IT WAS.
WE WILL HAVE THE PRODUCERS LOOK
INTO IT ON THE COMMERCIAL BREAK.
FIRST FOR THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
DONE AND PUTTING FORWARD A PLAN
IS A GOOD THING.
WHEN YOU AGREE WITH IT OR NOT I
THINK CAMPAIGNS ARE ABOUT
CHOICES.
AT THIS POINT ALL WE'VE HEARD
THE REPUBLICANS LARGELY SAY IS
WHAT THEY WERE AGAINST THEIR
AGAINST HUNTER BIDEN, JOE BIDEN,
DR. FAUCI THIS IS SUMMING UP
THERE FOR.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
CRITICISMS THAT'S WANTED AROUND
IS AN IN-DEPTH SENSE OF HOW THEY
ARE TO GO ABOUT IT?
IS THE PARENTS BILL OF RIGHTS AS
THINGS ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE CAMPAIGN BUT LOVE THE FACT
OF HER PEOPLE CHOICES.
FOR WOMEN, CHILDREN, AND
DOCTORS.
WERE REDUCING TAXES ON
MAINSTREAM BUSINESSES AND TAXES
AND GAS PRICES ARE COMING DOWN.
FRANKLY I THINK THE
QUINTESSENTIAL ISSUE FOR YOUR
KIDS AND MY KIDS AND OUR KIDS,
ALL OF US AROUND THE STABLE IS
WHETHER OR NOT WE EJECT RUSSIA
FROM UKRAINE.
YOU'VE TO GIVE THE PRESIDENT
SOME CREDIT THERE.
THIS IS A WIN-WIN FOR THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC TONIGHT.
AS WE FINALLY HAVE THE CHOICE
IS, THE OF THE REPUBLICANS, AND
THE CHOICES AND PRIORITIES OF
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE COUNTRY'S CAN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE.
DEMOCRATS ARE ENCOURAGED BECAUSE
THE POLLING DATA SHOWS.
WE CAN SIT HERE AND ARGUE AND
DEBATE, BUT WHEN THE NUMBERS ARE
GOOD FOR US WE BRAG ABOUT THEM
WHEN THEY ARE BAD FOR US YET TO
BE WILLING TO SAY WHEN THEY ARE.
THE POLLS HAVE TIGHTENED ON BOTH
SIDES AND BOTH SIDES HAVE LAID
OUT, AS A COUNTRY IS FOR THEM TO
SEE WHO MAKES THE DECISION.
>> Judge Jeanine: DID YOU SAY
ABOUT EJECTING RUSSIA UKRAINE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY.
>> I THINK WERE ALL IN THE SAME
WITH THAT, WE WANT RUSSIA TO
TAKE UKRAINE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I THINK THE
IMPORTANT THING IS THAT 300
PEOPLE ARE DYING A DAY FROM
FENTON ALL.
ONWARD ABOUT AMERICANS RIGHT
NOW.
PART TIME BECAUSE THAT BORDER IS
OPEN.
THAT'S LIKE MY PRIMARY CONCERN
IS AMERICANS.
>> NOT ALLOWING RUSSIA TO TAKE
UKRAINE.
>> Jesse: I KNOW HAROLD
THERE'S A LOT OF DIPLOMATS IN
TOWN IT'S GONNA SEEPING IN.
>> IF THE REPUBLICANS ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT FENNEL I THINK
THEY ARE, WHEN I WAS IN CONGRESS
THERE WAS REPUBLICAN NAMED
GEORGE W. BUSH WE HAVE A PACKAGE
TOGETHER WITH AN OVER THE TRIBES
OF THE KEVIN McCARTHY, THEY
SHOULD ALL SAY MR. PRESIDENT WE
HAVE A PLAN TO STOP FENNEL THE
BORDER LET US COME OVER.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHY CAN'T
JOE BIDEN COME OF THE PLAN?
>> THEY SAY HE'S DUMB,
INCOMPETENT, AND SENILE.
>> THAT'S WHAT SHE WAS TASKED
WITH.
CURRENTLY DO ANYTHING ON THAT,
IF SHE TO TEN-POINT PLAN I'D
ABSOLUTELY BE LISTENING.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING FROM
HER.
>> IF THEY HAD WHEN THEY DO TAKE
OVER THERE.
AT [LAUG